fuel is being courted by two brothers
Elmer and invites axel for an ice-cream
soda he's a villain the salary he gets
makes him a villain what have I done
what have I done give Rob the safe yet
dope EULA turns him down she doesn't want
to go around with accident elma the nice boy
wants to shake hands but axel says no nuts
she's going to pin a rose on him
what a beautiful love romance and
now they're going out to play post
office l must escape but axel says
Aylmer wants me so I'll answer
before he can change his mind
lucky Elma bring her he's going
to open both letters she should
have sent him Post Garden saved him the trouble i
wonder what to do no that wouldn't be right
so I'll do it he is now registering hate
looks like hydrophobia think I'll
deliver it in poison axel give him
the forge letter Elmer's all atwitter the
blow and his heart breaks all over the desk
the boss discovers the dirty work he
confronts Axl somebody's been playing
tag with the safe and you're it I'm
going to get a cop so don't you go
away Axl plays on elmer sympathy areas he
took samples home from the safe now watch
elmer thinking Beulah doesn't love him
he makes the big sacrifice no no not eat
was I for the third time Elmer wants to
shake hands but axle turns on him again
Oh cruel cruel cake Beulah accepts the Vipers ring
at the very moment of Elmer's released from prison
nice place you have here you must come over and
see us sometime she's getting Axel's number axel
is so excited he forgets the hang up the receiver
axel tells Elmer he's going to marry Beulah
no no you sick cracker you it shall not
be and they both go into the hands of the
receiver Elmer's broadcasting over station
aham but yes no oh my Elma I'm coming Elma
she's an Adagio dancer you rat says Elma
look out says Beulah sunk says axel I heard
every word but once I had a good connection
take back your ring my fingers green already
it's you I love see darling in
spite of my hay fever I've kept
your little goldenrod close to my heart
the forged note this was for you for me
so the happy ending the villain gets his
just as it then the hero wins the girl